et on va continuer à parler de la
situation royaume uni avec un direct
depuis londres de nat and fryer écrivain
et homme politique
bonjour johnattan fire merci d'être avec
nous ce soir sur rtl france alors trois
semaines au moins de confinement annoncé
par boris johnson est cette mesure
arrive tel trop tard et je crois dire
que pour l'instant il ya au sein du
parlement un espèce de solidarité
parlementaire c'est-à-dire même des
députés de l'opposition évite de
critiquer être fort le premier ministre
pour montrer que c'est vraiment une
crise nationale que ce qui est que nous
nous confrontant mais ceci dit cela dit
quand même comme un 10 les gens que vous
avez un début vient dans la rue il ya
beaucoup de gens ici qui ont dit
pourquoi pas avant au moins une semaine
peut-être deux semaines parce que on
suit de très près ce qui se passe en
italie est le stade de de l'épidémie si
en angleterre et plus ou moins l'italie
il est à deux semaines donc on sait ce
qui attend et on peut se demander
franchement pourquoi pas avant n'est ce
pas que plusieurs gens beaucoup plus de
gens vont mourir à cause de cette chose
et quelle est l'atmosphère aujourd'hui
qui règne au royaume uni est ce que la
population est soulagé justement de
cette prise de décision du gouvernement
britannique
je crois que la plupart dans la
population population était enfin
soulagé dans le sens que maintenant il
se rend compte que le gouvernement prend
au sérieux les menaces de cette épidémie
mais il ya beaucoup de gens bien sûr
surtout les gens peu âgées ou les gens
qui en août autre condition de sont est
difficile qui semble qu'ils ont peur
parce qu'ils ne savent pas s'il y aurait
des moyens au niveau des
le service de santé de l'est qui tombait
déjà sous pression qu'on parle la
semaine sachant d'ouvrir une grande
hôpital dédié au corps comme lieu de 19
de 4000 lits dans le centre expo de
londres mais ça ne serait pas assez si
vraiment une le virus se par un propage
comme en en espagne comme nokia les donc
certains sont soulagés mais beaucoup de
gens ont peur vous lisiez 1 4000 lits
d'hôpital vont ouvrir dans un centre de
conférence à londres
est ce que les mesures annoncées par
boris johnson hier et cette ouverture
d'un hôpital dans le centre de londres
est vraiment le symbole d'une prise de
conscience outre manche
mais il faut dire que londres c'est le
centre de l'airé dédiée ici en
angleterre le capital a beaucoup plus de
cas que d'autres lui dans le pays
donc oui c'est une signe de de crise
c'est une signe que quand même quand le
gouvernement
enfin prend au sérieux le problème le
chancelier 1.2 le ministre des finances
a annoncé des mesures extrêmement
important donc ils vont aider surtout
les grandes entreprises
des centaines de millions de lé de
livres qui vont être dispensés au
congrès où taux d'intérêt assez
intéressant mais quand même il ya
d'autres personnes par exemple sont
indépendants qui n'ont pas nous qui ne
sont pas salariés qui ont peur parce
qu'il ne gagne rien et comme vous avez
déjà montré monter dans la présentation
il ya toujours des chantiers qui sont
ouverts il ya toujours des ouvriers qui
sont payés jour par jour qui travaillent
et se met en danger dans cette situation
et là vraiment le gouvernement doit
prendre une
beaucoup plus fortement à mon avis la
boris johnson a édité un son revirement
de situation et de prise de décisions
peut-il lui et coûter cher politiquement
dans l'avenir dans l'avenir je crois
bien que oui pas demain par le mois
prochain mais dans l'avenir je crois que
ç'a vraiment peut-être la chute du
premier ministre parce que il cimente
est équivoque il ya qques un avis fait
avec des blagues pourrait [ __ ] face et
et pour alerter les gens ici mais c'est
pas le cas
ce n'était pas le cas surtout pour les
jeunes beaucoup de gens des centaines de
milliers de jeunes qui se promenait le
week-end passé au bord de la mer dans
les jardins publics qui se disent ah non
c'est pas grave ça ne va pas nous
toucher des gens évidemment surtout les
jeunes qui ne regarde jamais les
journaux télévisés qui ne suis pas qui
ne lit pas les journaux non plus et
évidemment son approche peut-être
critiqué il va être critiqué je crois et
pour lui ça va être très difficile de
sortir de cette affaire avec vraiment
fierté
merci beaucoup de jonathan nafkha fière
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir sur arte
france d'appel et que vous êtes écrivain
et homme politique merci pour ces
précisions direct de londres âme